bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
wazières à vis de vous retrouver depuis
l'ugc skywest à montigny le bretonneux
où se déroule le festival de
documentaires saint-quentin tout de
suite le sommaire de ce jeudi 29
novembre la 4e festival 1 a démarré
mercredi 28 novembre nous ferons le tour
de sa programmation interpellèrent le
théâtre et centre d'arles honda vélizy
ouvre la troisième édition de son
festival
un air de famille samedi 1er décembre
matif de bardot sera avec nous pour nous
le présenter puis nous irons faire un
tour sur ce sous ce chapiteau installé à
lille de loisirs pour y découvrir
dino expo le festival saint quentin a
commencé mercredi sur le thème de
l'espace vie films documentaires en
compétition à découvrir mais aussi des
grands films de fiction à redécouvrir
vendredi c'est une soirée star trek qui
vous est proposée par le geste et
skywest retrouver kirk et spock dès 20h
samedi la journée rythmée par de grands
succès américain de interpellèrent à
seul sur mars en passant par gravity le
festival n'oublie pas les plus jeunes le
dimanche avec les films d'animation
wall-e planète 51 et albator corsaire de
l'espace mais 50 1 ne se déroule pas que
dans les salles l'armée de l'air vous
apprend à piloter un drone au centre
commercial skywest lubezki vous propose
des conférences le groupe airbus
présente une exposition sur les femmes
dans l'espace
retrouvez toutes les autres animations
sur le site internet du festival et on
sort de l'ugc direction le cinéma art et
essai de saint-cyr-l'ecole les yeux
d'elsa bertrand pignet vous invite à
vous plonger dans l'univers de
l'animation japonaise au micro de
michael et demi d'euros
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine
on met à l'honneur le cinéma d'animation
japonaise pendant un mois au mois
d'octobre la mairie de saint cyr l'école
a mis à l'honneur le manga par des
expositions un concours de dessins à la
bibliothèque est évidemment beaucoup de
films et cetera qui ont été diffusées
ici et on clôt cet événement avec la
diffusion en avant première d'un film
qui va vous arriver sur vos écrans à la
fin du mois de décembre qui s'appelle
mirail ma petite soeur d'un monsieur
d'un grand monsieur du cinéma
d'animation qui s'appelle mamoru hosoda
il avait réalisé summer wars mais le
plus connu étant à mai et yuki les
enfants lui un grand succès à l'époque
de sa sortie
je vous invite donc à venir découvrir
mirail ma petite soeur de notre salle
c'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui
va avoir une petite soeur comme son nom
l'indiqué puis il n'est pas très
d'accord avec sa salle embête beaucoup
et par un artifice fantastico magique
comme souvent dans le cinéma d'animation
japonais il va se retrouver confronté à
son futur à son destin au destin de sa
petite soeur à mais aussi au passé de
ses parents et ses grands-parents
il va être projeté comme ça à travers le
temps et ça va être du coup donné une
sorte d'ampleur et de réalité à ce qui
peut être la notion de famille et de
lien familial en particulier au japon
mais c'est évidemment un thème universel
vous invite donc à venir le découvrir en
avant-première à 16 heures ce samedi 1er
décembre au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
3e édition du festival
un air de famille à londres à vélizy une
manière artistique d'entrer dans la
période de noël avec ses enfants du 1er
au 21 décembre avec nous en plateau
mathilde bardot bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes chargé de communication au
centre d'art une troisième et une
troisième édition ça y est ce festival
est installé oui en fait en réalité il
existait déjà un petit peu avant c'est
un festival qui s'appelait anciennement
la fête des mômes et depuis trois ans du
coup un air de famille est le but de ce
projet c'est vraiment de rendre
accessible le spectacle vivant et les un
classique au plus grand nombre et
notamment aux plus jeunes aux plus
jeunes qu'ailleurs il y aura une
exposition principale avec des
performances
c'est ça exactement l'exposition donc
ses clés die petitpierre qui viennent
revisiter le sapin traditionnel de
l'ondh
l'idée c'est cette année de le présenter
sous la forme d'une forêt d'épicéas qui
sera présente dans la rue traversante de
de l'undd et en parallèle de ça en fait
il y aura plusieurs performances
effectivement qui viendront ponctuer
l'événement pour faire vivre
l'exposition à travers le mois alors il
ya aussi des spectacles y en a trois oui
c'est ça tout d'abord il y aura donc
tombé du ciel qui
c'est un spectacle qui mêle la danse et
les dessins d'animation qui revisite le
petit prince
ensuite on horaires mythologie qui est
un spectacle donc de cléda et
petitpierre qui sont aussi
transdisciplinaire donc c'est vraiment
au coeur de ce qu'on fait à londres
et puis on finira avec 100% circus qui
est donc un spectacle de cirque comme
son nom l'indiqué et qui est vraiment
dédié aux enfants et aux parents aux
enfants et aux parents
donc c'est vraiment familial comme son
nom l'indiqué comment on fait pour y
participer parce qu'il ya aussi des
ateliers
oui exactement il y à des ateliers donc
il suffit d'aller sur le site ou d'abris
la billetterie qui donnera tous les
renseignements pour s'inscrire et sont
ils ces ateliers les ateliers donc en
fait c'est pour les parents et les
enfants salué les mercredis et les
samedis donc vraiment fait pour venir en
famille et ce sont des ateliers d'arts
plastiques où on aura des formes de
couleurs enfin j'en dis pas trop ivres
ou ça mais voilà familiale toujours sous
la thématique de noël
oui tout à fait tout à fait très bien
donc ça commence dès ce samedi 1er
décembre avec un goûter vernissage donc
à des animations particulières aussi
peut-être dès samedi et dur où il y
aurait une des premières performances la
première performance de créteil
petitpierre zéro degré on pourra
admirez la fonte de bonhommes de neige
dans la galerie diot et comment les
artistes sont venus à londres pour faire
ses performances là comment ça s'est
passée la collaboration
alors ça c'est la partie micron de l'ong
qui fait partie entière de notre
programmation mais qui est vraiment
dédié aux arts plastiques et donc là
c'est la directrice du centre d'art qui
mène un travail de recherches intenses
et avec les artistes et qui allaient
chercher que les dalles petitpierre pour
venir animer cette saison d'un air de
famille donc c'est vraiment une
ouverture des arts plastiques et à tout
le monde comme il exactement c'est ça on
le rend si une programmation qui est
vraiment dédié et qui est fait pour être
accessible aux enfants du coup très bien
merci bat il va revenir nous sur notre
plateau le festival à mère de famille
c'est du 1er au 21 décembre à londres à
vélizy et des dinosaures à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
dernier week end pour voir tyrannosaures
et autres velociraptor est passé son
diplôme de paléontologues aladino expo
un montage de sandrine fontaine
[Musique]
des dinosaures ont envahi l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
l'expo dinovo propose un saut dans le
temps sous son chapiteau 25 espèces de
dinosaures ils sont représentés nous
expliquons aux enfants comment ces
animaux ont vécu de quoi ils se
nourrissent et comment ils ont disparu
bien sûr un parcours présente les
différentes espèces et se termine avec
un documentaire sur la disparition de
ces géants du jurassique
les visiteurs doivent remplir un
questionnaire pour tenter d'obtenir leur
diplôme de paléontologues ont appris
beaucoup de choses sur les dinosaures et
surtout sur la façon qu'il vivait et
leur caractère assez atypique je trouve
en plus de l'exposition dino expo
propose un atelier dessin est un espace
de fouilles archéologiques qui intrigue
toute la famille pour moi c'est super
les enfants ils sont bien amusés ils ont
découvert plein de trucs et c'était
super l'exposition est encore ouverte ce
week-end du 1er et 2 décembre de 14h à
19h pas d'inquiétude pour les riverains
les dinosaures ne quitteront pas le
chapiteau l'association à gravure de
saint quentin en yvelines ouvre ses
portes samedi et dimanche
l'occasion d'échanger avec les artistes
autour de leur passion et pourquoi pas
d'acquérir leurs oeuvres
un vernissage petit déjeuner est prévu
le dimanche à partir de 10 heures 30
avec l'ouverture de la première case du
calendrier de l'avent arrivent les
marchés de noël
la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux ouvre le bal plus de 135
exposants seront présents pour cette 27e
édition 40% d'entre eux viendront pour
la première fois afin de vous faire
découvrir de nouvelles saveurs et la
magie de noël arrive aussi au domaine de
madame elisabeth les 1er et 2 décembre
un comptoir de noël sera installée dans
les jardins 500 m² de halle couverte
s'échauffer ou rencontrer une
quarantaine d'exposants qui présenteront
leurs produits de qualité plus qu'un
simple marché la demeure sera transformé
en véritable maison de noël des champs
dans le salon une table décorée dans la
salle à manger et même le père noël en
personne sera présent de nombreuses
animations seront également proposées
les animations diluée dans tout le parc
donc avec un carrousel
une ferme pédagogique un magicien qui va
qui va tourner sur l'intégrité de la
manifestation l'orangerie qui ouvre ses
portes toujours pour un salon de thé des
animations à l'intérieur
donc voilà l'idée c'était de trouver un
lieu dans des périodes de fin d'année
pour pouvoir accueillir est resté un bon
moment dans une ambiance conviviale
surtout et notez aussi que la ville de
bois d'arcy vous invite au domaine de la
tramblais ce week end
en plus des stands le marché noël
proposera des balades en calèche et une
initiation à la sculpture sur glace
côté sport le comité des yvelines de
badminton organise ce samedi 1er
décembre un événement bad au féminin au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
toutes les femmes sont les bienvenus
licenciés ou non l'occasion également de
découvrir le fit swinton
pensez à vous inscrire sur le site
internet et pour la semaine du handicap
la ville de maurepas vous propose
d'essayer des vélos adaptés aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
une sensibilisation aux handisports par
le club de cyclotourisme de la ville et
direction la seine et marne pour visiter
le château de vaux le vicomte le vicomte
l'ancienne résidence de nicolas fouquet
surintendant des finances de louis xiv
s'est parée pour noël le thème de cette
année les jouets anciens reportage de
nicolas le hérissé de nos confrères la
grand paris le château de
vaux-le-vicomte brille de mille feux
pour les fêtes de noël durant un mois et
demi l'ancienne résidence de nicolas
fouquet accueil guirlandes jouets
anciens et sapins illuminés
cela fait 13 ans maintenant que le
château se met aux couleurs de noël
nouveauté cette année des dizaines de
long terme illumine le magnifique jardin
dessiné par le nôtre cette atmosphère de
maison familiale dans laquelle on va
fêter en famille noël et on partage
cette célébration avec les dizaines de
milliers de visiteurs qui vont nous
rendre visite cette année pour leur
faire vivre un moment de rêve un moment
féerique en allumant les feux de
cheminée en ayant des odeurs dans chaque
pièce en mettant en avant les jouets
d'antan cette année et là effectivement
cédé l'aide cdld cas partout dans le
jardin qui assure les éclairages du
château et c'est la raison pour laquelle
on peut se permettre autant d'éclairages
et comme à l'époque du roi soleil tout
est mis en oeuvre pour nous éblouir 150
sapins dix mille objets de décoration 4
km de guirlandes lumineuses un écureuil
géant symbole de nicolas fouquet est une
thématique pour ravir petits et grands
cette année c'est les jouets d'antan et
là on s'est vraiment éclaté parce que je
me suis inspiré des souvenirs d'enfance
des grands magasins où il y avait des
vitrines extraordinaire avec une
multitude de marques de jouets ça c'est
génial
la famille est toujours présente à
vaux-le-vicomte c'est vraiment un
château familial ont créé les décors
avec l'équipe et après on fait le tour
avec la famille pour leur demander si ça
colore convient essayant des petites
choses à modifier qui est normal parce
qu'en fin de compte c'est pas nous qui
recevons c'est la famille qui reçoit le
public à votre vie 30
et pour compléter cette ambiance de noël
des feux de cheminée des odeurs de pain
d'épicés sont aussi au rendez-vous dans
le château toujours bien sûr sous le
regard bienveillant du premier
propriétaire des lieux et c'est la fin
de cette 11e édition de votre 7,8
loisirs mais le festival de
documentaires saint quentin se poursuit
retrouvez ce soir une soirée spéciale
temps x comme à l'ancienne à l'ugc
skywest et retransmise sur tv 78 quant à
moi je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]